Putting issues on the cable
so that we have to understand the
cultural mindset.
However,
there's far more in common.
Then there is indifference.
So in Asia,
in Japan,
other parts of Asia,
for example,
saving face is fundamentally a process.
You simply don't rip the face off of
another person.
You don't also open so much yourself in
the beginning because you don't want to
lose face yourself.
So it takes longer to build those bonds.
And if you're the same way in the Middle
East,
if you go to the Middle East,
you cannot go to was sued and buy
something without sitting inhabiting a
tea.
If it's a significant purchase in the
west,
we tend to be more direct.
What's your bottom line?
You go right to it,
which,
which are fundamental mistake.